on the morning of January 1st 2019 a
woman found her boyfriend unresponsive
lying in the bathtub EMTs were called
and attempted resuscitation but were
unsuccessful the two had stayed up for
New Year's Eve the previous night and
according to the girlfriend he showed no
signs of illness or change in Behavior
prior to going to bed no signs of injury
were
found overdose was ruled out as the
toxicology report found no presence of
Narcotics in his blood however anabolic
steroids specifically stanol nandrolone
and testosterone were found as well as a
small amount of alcohol it wasn't until
the autopsy that things became clear the
male was approximately 5 fo8 and weighed
187 lb his body had significant skeletal
musculature with low subcutaneous fat
and no signs of injury internal
examination revealed his organs were
congested due to impaired blood flow his
heart heart was significantly enlarged
tissue scarring was found in the heart
at the posterior wall indicating damage
to the heart muscle what you see here
are sections of the coronary artery
which supplies blood to the heart this
yellowish white region of the artery is
plaque buildup despite his age and
physicality he had severe
atherosclerosis an enlarged microscopic
image of the artery showed it had about
75% blockage this degree of blockage
would be found in an older person who
had a long-term diet high in saturated
fat and processed foods for several
decades instead it was found in a
24-year-old bodybuilder who was abusing
steroids both his girlfriend and
colleagues confirmed he had been taking
androgenic anabolic steroids for
bodybuilding his regimen consisted of
intramuscular injections of stanol
testosterone tamoxifen molone and
nandrolone he had no family history of
early atherosclerosis or cardiac events
the coroner officially ruled the
24-year-old had succumbed to Cardiac
Arrest due to an enlarged heart from
abuse of steroids cardiac issues from
steroid abuse are becoming an all too
familiar occurrence especially in
weightlifting and bodybuilding circles
since 2010 there have been 25 cardiac
related deaths among professional
bodybuilders with an average age of 35
years compared to other professional
sports bodybuilding has the highest
incidence of sudden cardiac death
followed by soccer at 17 basketball at 6
football at 4 and swimming cycling
Hockey baseball and MMA all at one
steroid abuse is common among
professional and amateur bodybuilders
and consequently can result in fatal
heart complications to better understand
how steroids affect the heart you first
have to know how hormones work after all
steroids act very similar to hormones in
the body one of the roles of hormones is
to allow the brain to control by bodily
functions to contract your muscles your
brain uses an electrical signal that
travels through nerves when this signal
reaches your skeletal muscles they
contract the nervous system cannot
control specific organ behaviors for
example the nervous system cannot tell
muscles to grow it can only tell it to
contract or relax this is where hormones
come in hormones can be thought of as
Wi-Fi there's no hardwire connection
like the nervous system yet the brain
can still get the message across
testosterone is a hormone that increases
muscle growth among other functions the
brain signals the testes to release
testosterone into the bloodstream
testosterone travels in the blood until
it binds to Androgen receptors on
skeletal muscle cells once bound to
these receptors a mechanism is initiated
that causes the muscle cell to increase
production of actin and myosin proteins
actin and myosin proteins form filament
structures which make up my fibral that
form muscle fibers which make up muscle
the more more testosterone that's
released the more actin and Milestone
that's produced leading to more muscle
it's because of this process that
testosterone is tightly controlled so
muscle growth does not become excessive
also other bodily processes require
protein so not all protein production
can be dedicated to muscle growth you
can get around this natural limit of
testosterone by injecting certain
hormones into your bloodstream that bind
to Androgen receptors one class of
steroids people use to do this are
anabolic and enic steroids or AAS these
steroids specifically bind to Androgen
receptors on muscle cells causing the
same mechanism that testosterone
initiates by consistently taking these
steroids skeletal muscle cells are over
signal to produce excess protein causing
more muscle growth on the surface it's
great you inject steroids work out eat
more protein and your muscles just keep
growing but unfortunately this is too
good to be true one thing people don't
realize is your heart muscle like
skeletal muscle has Androgen receptors
too as your other muscles grow in size
so does your heart stronger heart
muscles are beneficial to a point
because your heart can PT more blood and
has more endurance but it's not long
till this starts to become a problem
when the heart becomes too large it's
known as cardiomegaly the weight of a
normal heart for a man is between 280
and 350 G with any weight over 450 G
being diagnosed as cardial in some cases
of steroid abuse heart Mass has
increased to 580 G A 65% increase over
Normal Heart weight cardom megali has a
negative effect on cardiac performance
and can be fatal to explain how cardom
megali is bad let's look at how your
heart works the heart has chambers that
fill with blood muscles in the chamber
walls contract to pump blood out of the
chamber the more active you are the
bigger and stronger the muscles become
if the muscles grow too big such as from
steroid abuse they become inefficient as
they're too thick to fully contract
blood begins to pull in the ventricles
known as congestive heart failure you
would never know these issues exist on
the outside but on the inside it becomes
clear what better way to see what really
happens inside the body than through an
autopsy autopsies performed in athletes
who succumb to sudden cardiac events
were reviewed by several science
journals in this section of the video
I'll review some of those findings to
see what really happens inside the body
if in 2020 the science journal medicina
conducted a systematic review of 27
autopsies of athletes who had sudden
cardiac death the average age of the
subjects was 29 years 94% were male and
6% were female the subjects participated
in different athletic activities ranging
from cycling Marathon running
bodybuilding and weightlifting but the
most common activity was
bodybuilding 33% of the athletes had
cardio megali 30% had in large left
ventricles 79% had fibrotic scars on
heart tissue indicating acute heart
injury and 52% had necrotic myocardial
tissue necrotic heart tissue is tissue
that has died from lack of blood supply
to the tissue itself and is often found
in someone with a prolonged heart attack
not 29-year-old athletes due to
cardiovascular issues it's likely that
the heart had a deficit in performance
and oxygen delivery not surprisingly
this hypothesis is quite true this
Scandinavian Journal of Medicine and
sports found that athletes taking
androgenic anabolic steroids had
significantly higher hemoglobin in their
blood than non-users higher hemoglobin
levels means your body is not getting
enough oxygen due to an underlying issue
hemoglobin is a protein found in your
red blood cells it's responsible for
capturing oxygen when blood passes
through your lungs and then releases it
into your tissue to compensate for low
oxygen your body makes more hemoglobin
to increase the amount that's captured
Ed this is due to the fact that the
heart is not pumping blood efficiently
and therefore delivering less oxygen to
tissue what's interesting is high
hemoglobin is often found in smokers as
their pulmonary system is less efficient
at taking in oxygen the reverse is true
for a fit athlete a physically fit
athlete typically has less hemoglobin
than normal because their Cardiac and
Pulmonary systems are incredibly
efficient it's unusual that Physically
Active bodybuilders have elevated
hemoglobin pointing to underlying issues
what about the excessive plaque buildup
as seen from the autopsy of the
24-year-old is it related to his abuse
of steroids or was it from genetics or
even lifestyle it should be no surprise
that like any drug you put in your body
there's going to be side effects some
commonly known side effects of steroids
are increased acne atrophy of the testes
lower levels of natural testosterone and
mood swings one side effect you may not
know is how your cholesterol is affected
some Studies have found that anabolic
androgenic steroids increase LDL
cholesterol or bad cholesterol and
decrease HDL or good cholesterol The
Archives of internal medicine found via
systematic review that androgenic
steroids reduced good cholesterol by 52%
and raised bad cholesterol by 36% the
increase in bad cholesterol is not fully
understood yet the decrease in good
cholesterol is more clear there is an
enzyme in the body called itic
triglyceride lipase or htl which breaks
down good cholesterol by increasing the
amount of testosterone in the body the
activity of the htl enzyme is increased
thereby decreasing the amount of HDL
cholesterol in the body you may be
asking yourself if there's all this data
showing how bad steroid abuse is why
don't more people know about it there's
a couple of reasons first is sample size
on social media it may seem like a lot
of people are taking steroids yet this
is a biased perspective in a wider shot
chronic steroid abuse is much smaller
than you think for social issues smaller
group sizes result in less attention and
therefore change in the 1960s about 50%
of adults smoke cigarettes when the
Surgeon General came out with the
landmark study in 1964 linking tobacco
use to cancer many people were affected
and hence change was quick and
noticeable by contrast the number of
American adults who abuse steroids is
about
2.8% a tiny segment of the population
this tiny segment also makes for small
sample sizes in research therefore
limiting the number of studies that can
be published finally full disclosure
this is my opinion so take it as you
will a lot of steroid abuse is both
glorified and ignored on social media
specifically by Fitness influencers in
the current age of social media getting
lots of attention isn't Just A Rush of
dopamine those views translate to people
whom you can sell your customade fitness
program to or attract lucrative
sponsorships I firmly believe social
media and fitness influencers have
caused a rise in steroid abuse and it
will continue to grow into an epidemic
whether it's pressures of competition
obsession with achieving strength goals
or the hyperrealism of social media
people are being influenced to use
steroids after all why not partake it
worked out for them the fitness
influencer industry shows no signs of
slowing down on platforms like Tik Tok
Instagram and YouTube If people
especially young people are not made
whereare the dangers of steroid abuse
they will find out but through tragedy
thank you for watching Dark
[Music]
science